this was another huge mistake I'm on my
way I stopped in to like drive through
like Baton Rouge or something and I get
a tracfone and I call home and I call a
few people and I'd everyone so I would
do that when I was somewhere else I'd
call just to check out my mom my dad you
know so I call and I call a friend of
mine and she says look call the FBI
agent see if you can turn yourself in
and this point I'm pretty strung out
pretty exhausted I've had a bad couple
days so I'm I'm thinking okay so I call
the FBI agent name was a Candace called
her on mm-hmm
Candace is like a law-enforcement zealot
and really really did not like me just
despised me hmm I don't know why
everybody else was very pleasant so very
professional Candace was just vicious to
me and so I remember I called her and I
said hey my name's Matt Cox I just by
understanding you wanted me to call you
and she's like oh my god yeah mr. Cox
we've been looking for you
I said yeah I understand that she said
yeah I need you to turn yourself in I
said no I'm not gonna do that
and she said well let's talk about this
mm-hmm and she said we I go well what
what am I gonna get how much time and
she said well I mean that's not really
how it works you turn yourself in then
we determine we take that into
consideration I said yeah I'm not yeah
right that's not I'm not doing that and
she goes well I could talk to US
Attorney and see if he can recommend
something and okay so she so she's like
you do understand we're gonna catch you
no I'm not sure how well she's well I
mean let's face it she eventually you'll
get pulled over by the police I said
I've been pulled over by the police she
was well I'm you'll go to get a ticket
you'll try and hand him a driver's
license I said I've handed him driver's
license as a matter of fact I've gotten
like four tickets in different people's
names I actually went to traffic school
as another guy recently I got like three
tickets in his name he's gonna lose his
license I had a car in his name I had to
go Jesus so plus it was eight hours I
didn't have to spend with Becky right so
yeah so I you know I'm sorry I'm telling
her this and I and she's like you know
oh you know you're so cocky she said you
think you know
get away you know eventually you'll get
caught you'll get you'll you'll she said
you'll go home to see somebody somebody
will recognize you you'll get pulled
over
you'll somebody something will happen I
said listen nobody's gonna recognize me
he said I've had multiple plastic
surgeries I mean you know and if you
actually look at the pictures I mean I
mean I look vastly different hmm they
actually yeah anyway it's another story
yeah point is is that Mike look nobody's
gonna recognize me
I got multiple driver's licenses I've
got passports and other people's name
I've been in and out of the country I
said there's nobody in Tampa that I want
to see so unless we work something out
you're never gonna have this
conversation with me in person in person
and so she says okay she calms down and
I remember she said uh what'd she say
she kept calling me sweetie listen
sweetie listen sweetie and she goes I
remember she said you don't realize how
close we are to catching you she's we're
90% sure of where you're at I go yeah
well only a hundred percent counts
sweetie and she was just like I was oh
she hated me I was she was you know and
I shouldn't have been like I shouldn't
have you know just gotten down there and
started being snide back it was she was
so arrogant right you know and arrogant
people hate arrogant people right kids
you know so I I really hurt her
condescension was just like oh so we go
back and forth back and forth by the way
when I was eventually sentenced this is
brought up in front of the judge and
instead of me calling to turn myself in
and try and figure out how to turn
myself in and get a try and work out a
deal it turned into mr. Cox constantly
called the FBI and Moxa's talking about
I called a couple times so anyway I hang
up the phone it was she says she goes
okay I'll call you back I will wait a
minute I'll call you back she was just
leave your phone on I go no I said cuz
I'm gonna shut my phone off she goes
just leave your phone on I went I said
now you're probably tracking this phone
right now you're trying to triangulate
her or something and she goes she just
oke get over yourself
she's you're not that important and I
remember thinking
she's right who do I think I'm nobody
they're not trying to track the phone
it's just stupid come to find out when I
later ordered the judgment information
angry they were tracking the phone out
of Baton Rouge and they'd actually sent
two US Marshals to the to the 7-eleven
where I'd bought the phone where I was
sitting talking to her on the phone so
it just so happens that I hung up the
phone and I turned it off until her I
call back in a couple hours and I got up
and I got my vehicle and started driving
so I was driving when I called her back
a few hours later and I called and she
said look we talked to Robert miles a
Kowski which is the US attorney here in
Florida and Tampa says I can get you
seven years seven years and I thought
that's seven years and she doesn't even
know about the other side I already told
her look there's other stuff you don't
know about she's yeah but if you come in
first and you tell us about it we don't
charge you we'll take it into
consideration so I thought if I tell her
about the money and this and that I
might be okay mm-hmm
anyway I was like I'm not doing seven
years and she says look we can maybe
work something out like okay well what
about in Atlanta what about for Atlanta
and she's like well you need to turn
yourself in to Tampa so we start going
back and forth back and forth and
eventually what about the Secret Service
here she's like look you need yourself
into the FBI and Tampa just come back to
Tampa I went oh yeah but I'm closer to
Atlanta maybe I should just turn myself
in Atlanta and eventually it comes out
that I'm like look I've mentioned
Atlanta several times you won't even
address it did you talk to the US
attorney in Atlanta and she goes finally
she says no I didn't talk to the US
Attorney Atlanta I can only speak for
Tampa I go so the seven years is only
for Tampa and she is right yes I said oh
yeah we're done well I I wouldn't
believe you if you told me water was wet
it's over I just chucked the phone out
the window
[Laughter]